this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30
of americans struggle with sleep and i'm
a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back on
and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature my girlfriend runs hot all
the time she doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for
enhanced recovery so you can take on the
next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250
off of the pod pro cover that's a lot
simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m-eight sleep dot
com
slash tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they're worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things
that's why i use the theragun i use it
at night i use it
after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my
feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis i will
have my girlfriend use it up and down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n
try theragon risk-free for 30 days
there's no substitute for the gen 4
theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to
tim right now and get your gen fourth
era gun today
or you can watch the videos on the site
which show you all sorts of different
ways to use it
a lot of runner friends of mine use them
on their it bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start at
just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragon.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question now
with the
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of
the tim ferriss show my guest today is
dan harris who is dan harris after
abc news anchor dan harris had a
nationally televised panic attack
on good morning america in 2004 he knew
he had to make some changes
he found himself on a bizarre adventure
to reign in the voice
in his head that provoked his on-air
freakout and found a solution in
meditation
a lifelong non-believer meditation was
something dan always assumed to be
either impossible or useless
in 2014 dan published the book 10
happier which takes readers on a ride
from the outer reaches of neuroscience
to the inner sanctum of
network news to the bizarre fringes of
america's spiritual scene
and leaves them with a takeaway that
could actually change their lives in
2017
dan followed up with meditation for
fidgety skeptics subtitle a ten percent
happier how-to book
in 2016 dan launched the 10 happier
company that's
number one zero then percentage sign
with co-founders ben rubin ceo
and derek haswell vp of product the
company then was rebranded to
ten percent happier all spelled out in
2019
you can find dan on twitter at dan b
harris
that is harris with 1s on instagram dan
harris and facebook at dan harris abc
dan welcome to the show thanks for
having me
i'm so excited to dig into many many
many things and it's going to be
non-linear because that is my want
in terms of memento style interview
approach and i'd like to begin with
something i found
in the process of doing homework and
that is
a quote feel free to correct this if
it's
not accurate but here we go this is from
you
my career has been guided by a motto
bequeathed to me by my dad who is a
successful academic physician
and here's the motto the price of
security is
insecurity could you please explain
what this means and means to you yeah i
have so much to say about that
it really was my guiding light and still
is in many ways but in particular as a
young
journalist who was extremely ambitious
and again i don't necessarily need to
use past tense on all this some of it is
his present tense but in my younger days
in particular
i really believed that any success i was
achieving as i was working my way up the
ladder at abc news et cetera et cetera
was directly correlated to the intensity
of my anxiety
and that motto
handed down to me by my father who's an
academic physician was until recently
until he retired an academic physician
at harvard and a varsity warrior and you
know
long time hand wringer himself
was just my my way of kind of
almost like venerating the constant
worrying
i later found out from my dad that he
made that expression
up not to put worrying on a pedestal
not because he wanted me to be worrying
all the time because
if you think about it it's maybe not the
kindest thing to say to a kid
he in fact made it up because he wanted
me to feel better about the fact that i
was anxious
and i think that was give you permission
to feel the anxiety
correct you know i mean i was a really
anxious kid and
that carried into my adulthood
i would say now here i am 11 years post
beginning meditation i still believe it
is true
that a certain amount of stressing
plotting and planning careful thinking
is necessary if you want to be great at
whatever it is you're
you've set your mind to your work
parenting volunteer work
relationships except what i've now
started to see very clearly and i'm
imperfect at applying this but what i
see
really clearly is that we take the
worrying too far we take the insecurity
too far and we cross
the line between constructive anguish
and useless rumination and really the
self-awareness that i have generated
through meditation
imperfectly for sure has helped me
balance that
much more effectively and we're going to
go back to
the scene of the crime or more
accurately the scene of the
car accident psychologically speaking
back on air uh we're not going to resist
that just
yet but because you mentioned this line
and i'm going to
suppose apply it metaphorically here but
i had never heard of something called
and i've only read this and i could not
figure out how to pronounce it but the
yerkes-dodson law that i believe dr
luanna marquez brazilian-born now at
harvard
had told you about perfectly or
imperfectly
could you describe what the
yarkees dodson law implies or
claims to sort of describe in some
fashion because i this is quite freeing
to me
yes it really is uh so
luanna marquez came on my podcast right
at the beginning
of the pandemic and i want to do an
episode about
how to handle all of the stress that
that i knew
we were all feeling and we're going to
continue to feel for a while and
she talked to me about this i think it's
called the jerks dodson
and i was [ __ ] that one up before i
said it
i mean you can be forgiven it's a weird
i think it's the name of two scientists
hyphenated who came up with this idea
that a certain amount of anxiety luanna
marquez the aforementioned
harvard affiliated anxiety expert
was talking about the certain amount of
anxiety you can think of it as like
a curve like a bell curve a certain
amount of anxiety
is useful in that it gets us
moving it gets us protecting ourselves
it gets us
doing the things we need to do so that's
the beginning part of the curve the
upward slope
at some point it starts to slope
downwards and you can think of that as
the point of diminishing returns
where the anxiety is no longer
motivational
it's paralytic and so walking that line
seems to be in my own life it seems
it really has become one of the
most important arts and again
it's art not science and i have
nowhere near perfect and i don't expect
i don't think perfection is on offer
it also seems to showcase for me
the fact that there is a an evolutionary
value to anxiety
if we were to define it as the ability
to foresee
future threats and perhaps forestall or
mitigate them
right but when it bleeds over into
expecting catastrophe
and ringing your hands and biting your
nails at all times then it ceases to be
of utility right it actually ends up
being disabling but the
seeing it in graph form or in visual
form with the
jerks dodson law wikipedia
there we go correct corrected on lucky
number three
and was was really freeing in a sense
because
there's a desire that i find myself
succumbing to
which is to erase or
remove all anxiety and vilifying anxiety
is this
sort of shadow that i can't rid myself
of and
i liked reading about it i'll just put
it that way it's like give yourself a
break on some level
now speaking of giving anyone a break
if the price of security is in
was a motto that you kept in the back of
your mind
and assuming that you don't want
your kids to have a motto like only the
paranoid survive or something like that
what might be a motto you would want
your kids to have in the back of their
mind as they navigate
their lives the first 20 years 30 years
whatever it might be
can i give you two you you are allowed
to give me three if you'd like
i love mottos i love little expressions
mantras that you can use to kind of drop
into your mind
because it's so easy you know you can
listen to an inspirational podcast or
read a great book or whatever
and feel really like you've
you're invigorated you're uh you're
awake to some some important truth
but the habits of mind the old habits of
mine reassert themselves really quickly
and so
we need to find ways to to continuously
wake up
and to remember our aspirations and so
these little mottos i think you know
they can be a little bit cheesy but
but they're really helpful in my
experience so one of them
that specifically applies to this
question of how much
insecurity or anxiety is too much i i
got this motto from
my meditation teacher a guy named joseph
goldstein
you know i've heard you talk on this
show and i've heard you you you also
talked the one time we met in person
when you came on my show
i've heard you drop the name of jack
cornfield who's a legendary meditation
teacher and has had a huge impact on
your life
jack and joseph are old old
old co-conspirators from the 60s and 70s
when they
met both of them along with sharon
salzberg was another just
meditative titan the three of them all
spent a lot of time in asia
and came back to the states and founded
uh co-founded something called the
insight meditation society
and then jack broke off and started
something called uh spirit rock
meditation center on the on the west
coast
ims is on the left on the east coast and
so they they're really responsible for
bringing mindfulness
to the west in many many ways and so at
one
the first meditation retreat i ever went
on was at spirit rock where i know
you've
done meditation retreats and uh or at
least one and
tricky lady nervous breakdown retreats i
want to talk about that
so so i was on my first meditation
retreat at spirit rock and even though
that's the place jack founded joseph was
teaching for 10 days there and our
mutual friend sam harris
um got me off the wait list uh for this
no it's no regression
i should note no no relation although i
wouldn't be embarrassed
because i love the guy um
so i'm at this retreat and and i'll
spare you the whole story of the retreat
but the key moment as it pertains to
this question was toward the end of the
retreat
joseph is talking to the assembled yogis
the meditators and he says something
like
okay we're heading toward the end here
now and you might find your thoughts
start turning to the things you have to
do when you return to your life but
the best your ability you know try to
let those thoughts go
and i raised my hand because this was a
q a you were allowed to talk on an
otherwise silent retreat and i said well
wait
a minute dude if i miss my flight
that has real life consequences why
would you tell me not
to to think about that and he said no
you're absolutely right
but on the 17th run-through of all of
the horrible knock-on effects of you're
missing that flight
maybe ask yourself one simple question
is this useful
that is a great motto because of course
we're going to do some worrying and i
as uh you know a long time in veteran
fredder
i'm borrowing that phrase from the great
meditation teacher sylvia borstein as a
inveterate fredder myself i i'm i'm
cool with some worrying i think it you
need to do some of that
but at some point maybe ask yourself is
this useful and it's
at that point it's probably not and you
can like pay attention to what your
child is
trying to tell you or not mindlessly say
something that's going to ruin the next
48 hours of your marriage or whatever
just
live your actual life and so that to me
is a really useful motto i'll stop there
before i
go on to the second one unless you in
case you have something you want to add
or clarify
i have a follow-up question but i don't
interrupt the flow to number two so
let's go to number two
no no go ahead because this the the
number two is is so
so it's kind of off on a different thing
and i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't
wanna mess up your flow so go
ahead well my flow as such
is absolutely gonna take us off on a
wild tangent but that's okay
so you mentioned a few names you
mentioned
joseph is it goldstein or goldstein i
always mix this up because there are so
many different
goldsteins and goldsteins how does he
pronounce his last name he's a goldstein
yes
okay so goldstein salzburg
and cornfield right so i asked jack at
one point
jack i have to ask you this was in
private because
of course this is not the kind of thing
that you always want to ask in public
but i said jack
is there any reason why all of these
meditation and mindfulness teachers
these pioneers from the west and the 70s
are jewish
and he said that's a really good
question and we talked about he said
yeah it sounds like a law firm
and i would just love to hear
you have any thoughts on why
that is the case is it just coincidental
is there
something that maps from judaism to
buddhism
or otherwise do you have any thoughts on
that because
it is uncanny yes
i was just gonna say as it happens tim
ferriss i have a lot of thoughts on this
uh so these these people are all like
really good friends of mine now and they
go there's a i don't know how they feel
about this name
but there is a name for this
whole coterie which is the jubus
the jewish buddhists and the
prototypical jubu
is actually a jew he's a hindu but
his name is rahm das he is
yeah so you will be as because i know
you're a real uh connoisseur of and
supporter of
uh psychedelic or plant medicine and ram
das
born richard halpert alpert rather a
jewish guy from boston
became a harvard professor along with
timothy leary they got fired for
you know running experiments on their
students with either lsd or psilocybin
and he went off to india richard did and
discovered a hindu guru and named
himself changed his name to rahm das
and came back to the states and and
there's lots of good documentaries on
him i think some of them on netflix
and was extremely influential and
the slightly younger generation included
lots of people with like chewy jewish
names
uh like joseph goldstein sharon salzberg
jack cornfield sylvia borstein mark
epstein who's a psychiatrist in new york
city he's written a whole
beautiful series of books about the
overlap between
buddhism and psychology daniel goleman
who was a harvard phd then went on to
write become a science journalist for
the
new york times and then wrote um a book
called emotional intelligence which is
obviously a huge book
on and on tara brock is a slightly
younger
iteration of the same sort of trend on
and on and on you have these
great jewish meditation teachers so
what's going on here
uh and i say this as a half jew bar
mitzvah guy what's going on here
uh the jews i have a cultural
tendency toward anxiety which i would
argue is well earned from the
pharaohs through hitler and you know
that
yearning for some sort of
remedy to this really difficult
anxiety that plus the fact that judaism
in america
is largely not entirely of course but
largely secular
um i think created both a
hunger for answers to anxiety
and maybe a sense that there wasn't
enough spirituality in their lives
throw in the 60s and all the
psychedelics and the
and the vietnam and the and the
searching nature of that era
and you get the jubilees that's my sense
of course they may all yell at me for
being wrong about this but that's my
sense
well you're entitled to your
opinion and perspective on the whole
thing i certainly i'm not part of the
club so it's harder for me to have a
strong opinion of any type about this
it's also been a long standing
fascination of mine i have a lot of
jewish friends
to observe this
what seems to be fairly ubiquitous
anxiety
in many of the families i grew up around
many of the
friends i developed close friendships
with
in high school and college how much of
that do you think is cultural and
how much of that is survival of the
fittest in the sense if you think about
jews as having been persecuted for
like you said you know millennia since
the
time of the pharaohs is there just a a
sort of selection process over time
where the the
people who are the first to flee or
sense danger and move
are the people who then end up producing
sort of modern day juice i mean how do
you think
about that if you think about it at all
i think the evolution produced the
culture
and so we have this culture of anxiety
because
those the the jews that survived
learned to worry you know and another
this is skipping back a question but i
think another aspect of the
the sort of causality that led to this
remarkable
you know group of young jewish people
mostly from new york and some of them
from boston
who went over to india or asia and
learned how to meditate and came back
and and really became these
cra john kabat zinn i left him out who
was the he was the granddaddy of
mindfulness based stress reduction
without him
there is no secular mindfulness movement
a new york jewish guy went to mit and
studied microbiology and then
and then found zen and then invented
mbsr i think another
aspect of this is that all of these
people all of these names that i've
listened and these are all people that i
know quite well
they're incredibly smart and
i think if you add the anxiety
the spiritual yearning and the
braininess it all
is a perfect storm for buddhism because
buddhism
is incredibly interesting
there's the practice element which you
know
thinking can become can be a big
impediment to the practice
but the intellectual infrastructure that
supports
the practice is dense and fascinating
and it's it's a lifetime's supply
of ideas to wrestle with
and i think that's another component of
why these people
found this teaching so irresistible
i think one might also argue that
being well educated and having a lot of
cpu cycles in your prefrontal cortex
is also a perfect recipe for grist for
the mill in the form of anxiety
and rumination and open loops
for the salve in a sense that then is
mindfulness practice so let's let's dial
up the volume
on the anxiety to 11
to use a spinal tap reference i know you
have told this story a lot but there
will be people listening who have no
idea what the
catalyzing event looked like what
preceded it and so on could you walk us
through
your life from say 2000 and 2004
obviously we're going to use a montage
of some type or 2001 to 2004
to let's call it the event in quotation
marks
sure so in the year 2000
i as as a 28 year old
plankton from local news in in boston i
had i'd spent like seven years in in
local news in in uh in maine in boston
with ill-fitting
suits and way too much plaid at 28
i rode the escalator up into
abc news at the headquarters uh on the
upper west side of manhattan you've been
to our building
uh because you came on my podcast so you
know that escalator
and i was terrified
i had watched peter jennings my whole
life he was the
legendary anchor of world news tonight
until he died in in the mid
mid aughts and i was
just i was so thrilled but terrified and
this is where
price of security is insecurity kicked
into
high high gear and i had gotten this job
just complete luck
that i had gotten this job and i just
threw myself into it skipped
everybody skipped all my friends
weddings worked seven days a week just
was
clawing and scratching to get ahead in
an incredibly
venomous really competitive
unsafe in many ways psychologically
environment at abc news it's
it's improved vastly since then i'm
happy to report and
then not long after i arrived 9 11
happened
and i again driven by my
anxiety and also my idealism about the
role of journalists
are our duty to sort of bear witness at
the tip of the spear
i uh raised my hand and volunteered to
go overseas
after 9 11 and i ended up in
afghanistan with the taliban in kandahar
their capital at the time i think i'm
one of the last people to get a taliban
visa before they were overthrown
and just fell in love with combat
reporting
not because i like the gore but because
there's just it felt
so thrilling and so important
and of course there is the ego
aggrandizement of it too that you're
doing this important work you're living
in this
hyper adrenalized way and you're getting
on tv all the while um and so i got
hooked and spent
so much time in places like afghanistan
and pakistan
i covered the second intifada in 2002 so
israel the west bank gaza and then iraq
happened
spent months and months and months and
probably all together like a year
in on the ground in iraq and uh in the
summer of 2003
i came home and i got depressed but i
was
not self-aware enough to know i was
depressed so i started to sort of
i did something incredibly stupid which
is i started to self-medicate with
recreational drugs
including cocaine and ecstasy so i was
in my
early 30s at this point and i had never
i'd smoked weed and
and obviously drank a lot of beer in
college but i never done any hard drugs
and cocaine in particular really
my depression manifest itself as a kind
of
loginess or low energy i had trouble
getting out of bed felt kind of vaguely
ill all the time and cocaine this kind
of
synthetic squirt of adrenaline really
fixed that of course it had horrible
side effects like feeling
awful the next day etc etc and then an
even worse side effect which is
the aforementioned event on a warm june
morning in 2004
i was filling in on good morning america
and
at the time they had a job called the
news reader so you somebody would come
on at the top of every hour and read the
headlines
the person who had that job at the time
was named robin roberts who's now the
main host of good morning america they
don't have that role anymore but
i was in a rotation of regularly filling
in for robin and so
i wasn't particularly nervous on this
morning but for some reason
when the main hosts of the show charlie
gibson and diane sawyer
tossed it over to me to do my little
spiel i just lost it
and you can see this if you if you if
you type
panic attack on live television it's the
first result so
go for it uh you you can see it uh
has tenzo has millions and millions of
hits so i
start reading and then my
uh lungs basically seize up and my heart
starts racing my palms are sweating my
mouth dries up
and i can't talk which is a prerequisite
for anchoring the news
talking is um and it was
horrifying and so if you watch the tape
it actually does it looks
like i definitely look flustered and but
a lot of people say you know it didn't
didn't look that bad
and that's because i had the luxury of
being able to squeak out
back to you charlie and diane and they
took it back
but i had to cut the whole thing short i
mean i think i had read like two and a
half stories by the time
the freakout hit and it was awful and
really scary not only because
a panic attack is horrifying but because
i just thought well this is
the end of my career and my mom was
watching that morning and she
and she called me backstage and said oh
you just had a panic attack dude
and well she didn't say dude but anyway
she said you had a panic attack
and she hooked me up with a shrink and
the shrink asked me a bunch of questions
to try to figure out
what was going wrong and one of the
questions was do you do drugs
and i kind of said sheepishly yeah and
he gave me
i like to make this joke he gave me this
look one of these shrinky looks i'm sure
you've gotten this
look before tim from the shrinks with
whom you've worked
uh he gave me a look that communicated
the sentiment of okay [ __ ] mystery
solved
and he pointed out that even though my
drug use was
pretty intermittent and short-lived i
wasn't like
you know i wasn't like one of the people
from um
the wolf of wall street or anything like
that but it was enough to change my
brain chemistry and make a panic attack
more likely
so that's the story on that day
was there anything different about that
day leading up to it
anything at all that could have hinted
that this was not a day like any other i
mean do you have like itchy feet
and your eyeballs feel too big i mean
was there
was there anything symptomatically to
indicate that something was just
slightly off
or more than slightly off or did it
really come out of left field
left field man i i i hadn't i wasn't
high in the air i hadn't been
i don't think par i don't remember i
definitely hadn't been partying the
night before or anything like that maybe
in the week before but there was no i
had no
reason to foresee what was about to
happen and it sucked
uncontrollably
a quick thanks to one of our sponsors
and we'll be right back to the show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multi-vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around and right now
athletic greens is giving my audience
that's you guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so particularly in the
winter months adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support
so make an investment in your health
today and try the ultimate all-in-one
wellness bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim you'll receive up
to a year's supply of vitamin d for free
with your first subscription purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com
so my understanding is after
all of this happens and we're probably
skipping a few things so feel free to
fill in the blanks if you think that uh
that we should but
you were then assigned to cover
faith and spirituality against your own
wishes right
so you you began exploring mainstream
religion self-help spirituality
neuroscience and so on
and somewhere in that sort of chop salad
of spirituality and so on
was meditation like in there like a
like a crouton you found meditation
amongst everything
before we we jump to meditation though
i'm i'd be very curious to know was
there anything else
that you got exposed to
that was interesting to you not because
it was salacious or completely
a hoax but is there anything else that
really
seemed like it could be of value to you
outside of meditation
first of all the metaphor about the
chopped salad is awesome um
the the thing that's that really landed
with me about
religion the religions that i spent time
you know sort of
spent time marinating in i spent a lot
of time with evangelicals mormons
muslims i i as the child of
atheist scientists constitutionally i
just can't get myself to believe in
things for which there's no evidence
so i had a bit of an allergy
that maybe understating it to the dogma
and to the faith claims the metaphysical
claims and all that stuff
but what struck me was that
these folks were with regularity
contemplating their place in the cosmos
which i was
not doing i was utterly unreflective
in many many important ways and these
guys
on 11 o'clock on a sunday morning
or whatever time you know on a friday
afternoon if you're a muslim or a
saturday for the jews like they were
getting together and talking about the
universe
and that really hit me as somebody who
i had a sense of my own selfishness and
how that was making me unhappy
i didn't know what to do based on what i
was encountering from these folks
of faith because i found so many of
their beliefs to be
really hard to swallow but i i had this
kind of
i don't know i'm going to use a word
that i don't know how to pronounce i
think it's
in coheit this kind of this
beginning i know the word you know that
word right you see it in like
fancy books and like you never know how
to pronounce it but i had this kind of
beginning
inkling that yeah there's something here
that i that i should pay attention to so
as you're paying attention then
how does meditation first come over the
transom
what was the first exposure that
actually made you raise an eyebrow and
go huh
maybe there's something i should pay
attention to here yes i'm a hard case so
it took me a while but
the first the first first exposure was i
was
shooting a story it was when right after
sarah palin was nominated to
by john mccain as his vice presidential
candidate and i was
she's a she's a pentecostal so i was
doing a story in jersey city
about pentecostals i was shooting at a
street fair
with some pentecostals and uh trying to
get a sense of like what that
flavor of evangelicalism was like to
educate
the american publisher did you have
something you wanted to say there i was
just gonna say for people who don't know
anything about pentecostals you should
add some color here because
it is it is a fascinating flavor
yeah yeah so these are the folks that
like speak in tongues i mean
there's there's a i don't want to
describe pentecostalism as a monolith
because there are flavors within the
flavor but
but you know when you and and there are
non-pentecostals who speak in tongues
too but
they're sort of charismatic and that's
actually a term of art the charismatic
christianity where
you uh some of them will will handle
snakes during services
or speak in tongues um which is a kind
of like
you're you're speaking in tongues is
like you're speaking a
a nonsense language that is in some way
divine that you're being taken over by
the holy spirit
so it's a really dramatic
and again i think they'll use the word
charismatic form of christianity
thank you for the context please
continue didn't want to interrupt too
much
no you interrupt me anytime because i i
i like tangents so anyway i'm i'm out
shooting the story
this story pentecostalism has nothing to
do with what is about to happen which is
that i was
waiting when you're shooting a story
there's like lots of
down time and so i was chit chatting
with the crew
the the cameraman the sound man and our
producer
felicia barbarica who is uh still a uh
actually she's quite senior producer at
world news tonight
at that time she was a field producer so
she and i were covering the story
together we had known each other
for quite a while and she started
talking about
a book a self-help book she was reading
by a guy named eckhart
tolle who i had never heard of and
felicia said something like dan you know
you should read this book
it's all about controlling your ego and
me and the crew started laughing because
it was clear to us that she was saying
you have an out of control ego
which by the way was true and so it was
very funny but it wasn't what she meant
which she meant and what totally means
by the ego i subsequently learned
because i went out and ordered his book
and read it
or one of his books and read it what
totally means by the ego
is the non-stop conversation we
are all having with ourselves this inner
narrator
this constant flow of thought and urge
urges and emotions coursing through our
minds
into which very few of us have any
visibility
and so i i i started to read tully's
book
and at first i thought it was complete
nonsense because he he layers in lots of
like
talk about vibrational fields and
spiritual awakenings and all this other
stuff
but when i got to the stuff about the
ego which again he has a much more
expansive definition of this sort of
inner ghostly sense of you
that is constantly spewing sort of
self-centered thoughts hurling us into
the future or ruminating about the past
to the detriment of
the here and now when i read
his diagnosis of the ego which is
essentially just the human condition
that was a gigantic waking up moment for
me because
first of all it was just like oh yeah
that is true
and it also really explained my panic
attack because it was my ego and again
not just the sort of stereotypical parts
of the ego the like self-aggrandizing
part but also like
all of the fear and idealism and all
this
sort of unseen mental machinery
that propelled me to cover
combat without really thinking about the
psychological ramifications
it was the ego the sort of mindless
inner conversation
that allowed me to come home get to
press not see it and blindly reach for
cocaine as a as
medicine and that all produced the the
panic attack so
it was reading eckhart tolle that was
really the first step toward me
getting interested in meditation and the
problem with eckhart tolle was
that he didn't offer any actionable
advice
felicia and i ended up flying to toronto
to meet
totally uh he lives in vancouver but he
was giving a speech in toronto and he
gave us
an audience in a like beige hotel room
and and i interviewed him and i asked
him you know what it was actually the
first
interview i did with anybody in the
faith world where i like felt like i had
some skin in the game because i was
really interested
and i tried to get him to to answer like
what do you do about the voice in the
head and i remember at one point he said
take one conscious breath
and my voice in my head was saying what
the [ __ ] does that mean like what are
you talking about
give me something to do here a friend of
mine has described
totally as correct but not useful
and so he woke me up to a
thunderously obvious but regularly
overlooked fact which is that we all
have minds and our thinking
but he didn't give me anything to do
about it still very valuable to say hey
bro you got a huge abscess in your gums
or whatever it is right even though you
might not be the surgeon or the
orthodontist or whatever the specialty
would be to take it out a helpful first
step
correct it was it was really helpful
first up
i'm thankful for him what happens at
that point you're like you've
diagnosed i don't want to say the
problem the condition let's call it
to where does dan harris go at that
point
shamelessly leveraging all the privilege
of my journalistic perch
i basically started with the
aforementioned felicia we started doing
lots of stories about self-help
because i thought you know somebody in
this ought to be able to tell me more
about like what to do about this
so i ended up doing all these stories
about you know deepak chopra who i think
is on the farm
i mean i make fun of deepak you know
with gusto in my book but
nonetheless i think he's on the far
benign end of the self-help spectrum
and then we i did lots of stuff on the
folks who are way more questionable to
sort of
solve all of your problems through the
power of positive thinking crew
you know the secret and uh i did a lot
of stuff on
james arthur ray i believe his name is
the guy who had that sweat lodge
ceremony where people died
and basically i was completely
completely
unimpressed depressed confused didn't
know what to do
and actually during this period of time
i came
home one night to my then apartment on
the upper west side of manhattan and my
then fiance
and now baby mama bianca
gave me a gift as i walked into the
apartment that evening
she said i've been listening to you talk
about deepak chopra and eckhart tolle
and blah blah blah
and not making much sense as you do but
it vaguely reminded me this is her
talking or vaguely reminded me of
a book i read many years ago and here it
is
and the book was by a guy i mentioned
earlier on the show when we were talking
about the jubus
named dr mark epstein i liked him right
away because he had actual credentials
he's a as i said a shrink lives and
works in new york city
and he's written all these incredible
books about
the overlap between buddhism and
psychology modern psychology and
so i started reading one of his books
that night the book i
started reading was going to pieces
without falling apart
and it was my total it's a great title
it's a great and it's a great book i
highly recommend it and
and it was the first it was my first
introduction to both
buddhism and meditation did you begin
some type of practice after that book
did it give you the prescriptive
how-to in a a form of self-help that you
did not have
anaphylactic shock in response to yes
i had hives on the regular when i was at
the company scientological hives popping
out everywhere
that's a really good phrase i might
steal that um
steal away i'm hi i have like five
million milligrams of caffeine in my
system so
i'm on fire please continue so so
yeah well as somebody who has a panic
disorder i can't have caffeine but i'm
just
it's the poor man's caffeine continue
so so i i am a tough case as i
referenced before so i
read about buddhism was really
interested in buddhism
but the talk about meditation i found
repellent and
so i i was very very resistant and
what finally brought me over
to trying it was so this is like 2009
i as i started researching meditation
i came across some of the science that
really strongly suggests that meditation
can confer a long list of tantalizing
health benefits
and at that time that science was not
well
publicized and so i had this inkling of
oh this is a huge story that people
don't know about
and i had this kind of entrepreneurial
itch of
meditation appears to be really helpful
and all these books i'm reading or many
of the books i was reading because i
started reading a ton
are really annoying and
i could write a book that uses the word
[ __ ] a lot and like tells embarrassing
stories
and maybe that would reach people who
otherwise would never do this thing
and so i started
after really looking at the science and
kind of reviewing it with my wife as a
scientist
i was really convinced that there was
something here so i started doing like
five to ten minutes a day
and it really helped and then after
about a year of that
i met sam harris i actually re-met him
i had met sam once years before and then
i met him again i was moderating a
debate that he was in
against deepak chopra and he actually
dismantled him you can you can see that
on youtube too
and sam i loved uh and i still love it
as a general rule you do not want to
debate sam no
he's very scary actually the thing about
sam and you know this tim because you
know him is like
he can seem very intimidating but if you
interact with him especially if his
wife's around
and his wife is an extraordinary person
annika harris who's written
written a great book about consciousness
you know he he she can reduce him to
like
a blub you know giggling you know
red-faced ball
a puddle which is amazing and he's like
a he's really warm and
uh incredible and he told me about
joseph goldstein and got me into this
meditation retreat and
that really cracked things open for me
and and i would say since doing that
retreat for the last decade it is just a
non-negotiable part of my life
is it part of your life on the frequency
of
daily a few times a week what is the
current
or when you are at your best when you
are your best self
let's just say what is your frequency of
practice
all right so that i'm going to by forget
the answer here because i'll answer for
me and then i do want to say a few
things about
because i think the question that's
probably coming up in the minds of some
of your listeners
is like what's the least i can do
to get all of the advertised benefits so
i'll say
i'll say something about that too but i
don't want you to be discouraged by what
i'm about to say which is that
for me it's every day once in a blue
moon i will miss
a day because something has you know
like that it's just gotten totally crazy
or whatever
and i went through a period where i did
two hours a day which was
way too much not in that it was it was
nuts it was
it was just eating up too much of the
rest of my life so now i do about an
hour a day but i'm much more relaxed
about it and i kind of
my rule has always been and this was
true even when i was doing two hours a
day is like
i can do it whenever i want wherever i
want and in whatever increment
i want so it may be five minutes here 10
minutes there
on a really good day i'll get
a long sit you know 30 45 60 minutes
but on many days it's just like a
succession of smaller sits
and uh or i'll do a walking meditation
so yeah i'm pretty consistent but i
don't think that's that's
necessary for beginners i really think
the access point here is
really easy and user friendly and
what i say for my two little mantras
little slogans here i go again
for for beginning meditators one is
one minute counts i really think and we
can talk a little bit more about how to
do the practice but i really think that
even in a minute you can start to get a
sense of oh yeah i've got this inner
cacophony
and i don't need to be owned by it so
it's the visibility that is the
kryptonite
for the ego that seeing it really
defangs it which is kind of amazing
and that can happen in a minute would i
love to see you do five to ten
sure but we know that habit formation is
really hard diabolically hard so
setting the bar really low i think is
very helpful and then the other little
slogan is
daily ish you know yes would it be great
if you're doing this every day sure but
if you
grit your teeth and tell yourself you're
going to do it every day the first day
you miss which inevitably you will
the voice in your head will swoop in and
tell you you're a failed meditator and
then like deuces you know you're out
and and so i think daily-ish has like
elasticity and flexibility in
in it that i really like yeah it's like
brushing your teeth right you miss a day
your
your your teeth aren't going to
disintegrate you miss you
20 30 days then you might have an issue
that starts to crop
up back to the abscess back to the
abscess i don't know why i'm so focused
on
dentistry today but the question for you
about the subjective experience
of this is a
regular practice for me in my own
personal experience
the value of meditation which i can find
tremendous benefit
in 10 to 20 minutes a day done
consistently i i find tremendous value
the value is not always obvious when i
am doing it but it becomes more obvious
if i suddenly stop for a period of time
i would just love to hear what does dan
with meditation look like compared to
dan
without if you suddenly go cold turkey
for a period of time for whatever reason
or however you'd like to tackle that
just so people can get a grasp on
the benefits as you experience them
that was just really well articulated
when you talked about your own practice
because
this is perhaps the hardest thing to
understand about meditation
because all of us i'm making an
assumption here but i think it's safe
for your audience we're all
type a people we do something and we
expect to
succeed we expect to win so we
we go into meditation with expectations
which are the most noxious thing you can
bring to the
party so in a in
individual sitting or walking meditation
in an individual session of meditation
the
goal is not to feel any certain way
in fact going into it if you're
expecting or hoping to feel a certain
way
it pretty much blocks you from getting
there
the goal instead is to feel whatever
you are feeling clearly so that you
build the muscle
of not being owned by your feelings let
me just say that again because it's a
little hard to understand
when you sit to meditate you're you
really don't need to like will yourself
into a bulletproof
bliss bubble instead you should just be
noticing whatever's coming up you know
i'm planning lunch i'm planning a
homicide
i'm um you know uh i'm i'm jealous of
uh uh of like i'm i'm remembering
primordial anger toward
my younger brother whatever is coming up
and that
is correct meditation because the
visibility is the kryptonite seeing
clearly
the cacophony of your own inner
landscape
is how you are no longer
owned by it and over time
so you can have a whole week of
quote-unquote bad
sits where you're totally distracted or
you know you're restless or you're
sleepy
but over time the net effect of it
is that you are more self-aware
and therefore less yanked around by the
malevolent puppeteer of your ego
and so for me what i notice and actually
this is why falling off the wagon
can be really helpful because it can
increase your faith
in the practice what i notice is that if
i miss a few days
my inner weather becomes much more you
know stormy and i'm likelier to
eat too much or to you know make a nasty
comment
be impatient beat myself up more
be more judgmental when i look in the
mirror etc etc i can just really
see the venom quotient increase
when i'm not doing this thing you use
the word weather
and i can't remember who
shared this imagery with me at some
point but they said you know the
difference between
experiencing as you experience without
meditation and with meditation
is like standing outside
in the rain in a storm versus standing
inside looking out the window at the
storm
and there are a bunch of other analogies
that i like i mean one would be
being 18 inches outside of the
washing machine looking at the clothing
versus being inside or
sitting in the audience watching the
movie
of your emotions versus being in the
movie right there there are these
all these analogies or metaphors that
imply a level of observation and
detachment although i'm sure some
psychologists would take issue with that
term
what does the practice look like what
does your actual practice look like
because there's so many ways to meditate
right it would be like saying
i do sports it's like well what are we
talking about racquetball
swimming you know curling what are we
talking about here so in meditation what
is your
particular format what does it look like
that's exactly right that there are many
many forms and people can get pretty
dogmatic about you know their support
for whatever
meditative team they've chosen the kind
of meditation that i generally
talk about publicly and that you know we
teach on
my app and everything is called
mindfulness meditation
which is derived from buddhism but
and i i talked about john cabot zin
before this was his
innovation he was this mit whiz kid who
discovered zen and then it was on a
meditation retreat a buddhist meditation
retreat and had this
insight that like oh if we strip this of
its religious
lingo and metaphysical claims we could
teach it in secular contexts
such as health care and people who
otherwise would reject it
might embrace it and he invented an
eight-week protocol for teaching what's
called mindfulness
based stress reduction and secularizing
it
and giving it a structure of an
eight-week teaching program
that is what allowed for science
scientists to come in and say okay well
we can this is replicable now
we can run this on a bunch of different
populations and
measure their cortisol levels and look
at their brains etc etc and that's
what's given us this
in large measure that's what's given us
this explosion of research into
what meditation does to the brain so
that's the kind i was initially
attracted to
and the kind of meditation that i now
evangelize
for i have over time and this is totally
optional but for me i've over time
gotten
more interested in the buddhist
antecedents
and so i would describe myself as a
buddhist
but in the sense that there's a great
author
named steven batchelor who wrote a book
called buddhism without beliefs
and he describes buddhism not as
something to believe in
but as something to do and in that sense
i'm a buddhist
in the in the maybe in the same sense
that i'm a journalist it's like it is
something that i do regularly but i'm
i wouldn't sit here and pound the table
on behalf of rebirth
but i do think that the buddhist
practices are uh just a revelation
and just like just a vast treasury
really so what does the practice look
like beginning mindfulness meditation
really is very simple you just
find a reasonably quiet place and sit
with your spine reasonably straight you
don't have to be uptight about that in
fact being uptight is
not recommended in any aspect of this if
you don't want to sit
first of all you don't have to be in you
don't have to fold yourself into a
pretzel i don't you can sit in a chair
you can also lie down
if you're feeling sleepy and or worried
about falling asleep you can stand up by
the way falling asleep is not a problem
very common
and actually a good sign that maybe you
need more sleep so that's the first step
find a reasonably quiet place
comfortable position close your eyes if
you don't like to close your eyes you
can kind of just gaze softly at a
neutral spot
second step is bring your full attention
to the feeling of your breath coming in
and going out
pick one spot like your belly or your
chest or your nose
and just kind of commit to feeling that
and and that's a key word here feeling
because you
we do we spend most of our life trapped
in thought
but actually we're in this practice kind
of dropping below the level of thought
and
tuning into the raw data of the physical
sensations of the belly rising and
falling the chest rising and falling the
air
entering or exiting the nostrils
and so that's step number two just oh by
the way i should say that if some people
find the breath
to be anxiety producing and and that's
actually not uncommon especially now
like covet has a pulmonary
implication obviously and blm has a lot
of
uh stuff about not being able you know
people i can't breathe has become a
really
a really resonant in a difficult way
phrase so if the breath is hard for you
you can just focus on the feeling of
your body sitting or lying down or
standing or
pick one spot on your body like your
hands whatever they're touching
and just commit to that and that's the
the third step is
as soon as you try to do this thing
which is going to sound reasonably
simple you'll realize it's infernally
difficult because your mind will go into
mutiny mode it's like
it's like trying to hold a live fish in
your hands like it it's just slipping
away from you
all the time you know it's like you're
planning lunch or you're planning some
you know expletive filled
speech you're going to deliver to your
boss or you know like random
what was casper the friendly ghost
before he died or just like your mind's
all over the place
and that that is the moment
most people think they are failed
meditators
but i'm here to tell you that is the
moment when you notice you've become
distracted even if it's for
the whole session just noticing that
you've become distracted
is proof that you are meditating
correctly because
as i said before the goal here is not to
cl actually i haven't said this yet
this is really important the goal is not
to clear your mind
because clearing your mind is impossible
unless you're enlightened or you have
died
the goal here is instead to focus your
mind
for a nanosecond or two on on something
like
the feeling of your breath or the
feeling of your body sitting and then
every time you get distracted you start
again and again and again and
that act of noticing the distraction and
starting again
is like a bicep curl for your brain and
this
is what we see on the brain scans of
meditators this is the mechanism by
which we're training
your attention we're boosting your
ability to focus
we're boosting your self-awareness and
that's self-awareness that
regular sort of systematized collision
we're engineering in meditation with the
voice in your head that is
revolutionary because as soon as you
start to see
how chaotic your mind is and i know i'm
banging on about this point but it's
just
you can't say it too much as soon as you
start to see the chaos of your own mind
that's the first step toward not being
owned by it and
you know i just think that's you used a
bunch of analogies earlier another
analogy that
john kabat-zinn uses is you can think of
the mind like a waterfall
and the thoughts and urges and impulses
that's all the water
flowing ceaselessly down the waterfall
mindfulness which is the self-awareness
that we're generating through meditation
is like the crevice in the rock face
behind the water that lets you
and now i'm mixing my metaphors kind of
step out of the traffic and to view the
contents of your consciousness
with some non-judgmental remove and this
is not new age
nonsense we are classified as a species
as homo sapiens sapiens
the one who thinks and knows he or she
thinks
and yet that capacity this birthright of
yours
is atrophying for many of us because in
our culture at least nobody points out
that we have this bonus level in our in
our brain and
so that's what you're developing in
meditation i want to come back to
the bicep curl because i think it's
a helpful way to view the practice at
least it's been helpful for me
and that is i'll pull from a different
type of meditation for just a second
because
for all it's all the criticisms levied
against tm i do think that
some transcendental meditation teachers
which is
a mantra based practice have a way
of setting the pass fail bar
very low to help you
practice consistently in the beginning
and i think that's
really important i mean if you decide as
a type a person like anything worth
doing is worth overdoing
therefore i'm gonna sit in full lotus
two hours a day
five days a week that's my resolution
the likelihood of you failing is is
almost 100 right but if you
instead come into it as i was
advised at one point when i've practiced
tm is
if you say your mantra once i mean this
is like one or two syllables if you say
it once in a 20 minute session that is a
successful session
right then for someone who's accustomed
to trying to
put points on the scoreboard and compete
it's the proper sort of mental
contortionism and trickery
to get me to do it two or three days in
a row and
i found that extremely helpful and the i
can't remember if it was tarbrock or
sharon salzburg who said to me i think
it was one of the two who said
the bringing the attention back from
casper the ghost to your breath
even once like that's the bicep curl
that's the repetition that that is the
practice
the practice isn't sitting there like a
bodhisattva
in this single-pointed experience of
universal consciousness for 20 minutes
the practice is thinking about pornhub
or different strokes or like dunkin
donuts and then coming back to
the breath once like that's the rep
that's when you earn the points
which was just an incredibly helpful
reframe for me you can have an
incredibly messy seemingly messy
meditation practice and still consider
it
successful which was difficult for a
sort of compulsive type a personality
like yours truly to
get a toehold on in the beginning amen
to everything you just said that was
just all
perfect and and difficult for me too and
and
and which is why to me the biggest
revolution
in my own practice and this is just goes
back to me being a hard case because
this is recent for me when great
meditation teachers
give the beginning instructions they
often say
you know it's not a cold clinical
detachment with which we're viewing
the contents of our consciousness it's
actually a
they'll often use the word which i've
traditionally found quite overwrought
but like a
loving awareness and i completely
ignored that part of the instruction
and over time what i have found this
actually will bring me to the second
slogan i was going to try to
get to at the beginning of this cover or
earlier in this conversation
over time i've really started to add
into the mix
instead of like a cold maybe you might
say
journalistic remove on the various
machinations of my ego that i'm
witnessing when i sit in meditation
to bring a warmer friendlier
again maybe even loving sense as i'm
viewing you know all of my ugliness
that has been a revelation and what
which brings me to the slogan which is
you know i think in our western
individualistic
uh culture we think of
spiritual quests as like a slaying the
dragon
which is pretty violent and so i
actually think it's more like hugging
the dragon
and that that is like a
radical disarmament because i've just
noticed as i see like my own selfishness
or
my own jealousy or my own impatience my
own self laceration
if i can see that as like ancient and
you i heard you talk about this recently
on
on that incredibly brave podcast you did
about the childhood abuse you suffered
if you can start to
view these storylines as
their ancient storylines they're ancient
inner characters
who are trying to help you and they made
sense they were adaptive at some point
in your life
but they aren't working now but instead
of like slaying those dragons which by
the way will only make them stronger
if you hug them if you give them a high
five and a seat at the table and a party
hat
they will quiet down and you can then
make a better smarter decision
yeah totally for whatever reason i was
thinking of
like this tiny huffy bike that i had as
a kid
huffy some people recognize that name oh
my god this tiny huffy bike
with like the padded handlebars bmx with
training wheels and that's a great bike
when you are the proper size but if
you're still trying to ride that
when you're in your 20s 30s and 40s that
is
uh you're gonna have some panty pinches
that's very uncomfortable right so it's
perfect for a time
and is no longer the right tool for the
job but it doesn't mean you have to
throw it in a trash compactor and
write curses all over it it um also
brought up a memory of a
pin that my mom bought for me i think it
was
last summer for my birthday which says
sometimes i wrestle with my demons
sometimes we just snuggle and i thought
that was a pretty good
reminder for mindfulness practice
uh what is your relationship with
anger and that could be past tense and
present tense but
i have read that
one of the let's call it difficult
emotions that you still
experience regularly this is at least an
interview in 2018
was anger could you speak to your
relationship with anger or how that has
been a
presence in your life a prominent inner
player
and i'm still like kind of working on
this so uh
what i'll say is just maybe going to be
not polished um just as a joke to start
i uh
chris cuomo who used to work at abc news
and we became friends back then but he's
now a
cnn primetime host he wrote an article
years ago for
some men's health magazine or something
like that and he talked about
his emotional landscape having two gears
anger and self-pity and uh
which i thought was just so great and so
perfect for me in some ways because
those those
two emotions are just so prominent for
me and particular
anger and it's a not man it's
just a you know i i will get
angry because you know just saying i'll
get angry at somebody
i'm working with because if they're not
doing a good enough job
it threatens my high standards for my
work which then threatens my
safety my you know it triggers my
anxiety
and i will lash out
and then i'll lash back at myself for
being such a horrible
mean person and that is
really hard to untangle and
this is where the hugging the dragon
becomes
really useful to see at the root of that
is fear right anger is often described
as a secondary emotion it's usually
something that happens
as a knock-on effect of a more primary
emotion in my case
over time i've just seen the emotion
that seems to be at the root of so many
of my
problems is fear anxiety
and so it can lead to as a knock-on
effect this anger at other people but
primarily
there's not so much blowing up at other
people going on in my life
now but a lot of anger at myself
i can get into whole loops around i'm
approaching 50 and
the abs that i had in my mid-30s are now
not visible in any way
unless you have a high powered
microscope and you know i can get into a
whole thing around that and
and it's like this anger at myself for
being sloppy or not
being up to my old standards or whatever
and the same thing can happen
around my productivity levels there's a
great phrase i heard
from a podcaster named jocelyn k gly
she has a phrase productivity shame
which i just love that you know like i i
you i know you're writing a book i'm
writing a book right now and like if i'm
not hitting my
cadence for completing a chapter it's
just there's there's just so much anger
at myself and so
it's been really useful i've worked with
this coach who i know you know
uh jerry colona yeah and i've been
working with jerry for years he's an
executive coach but in many ways it's
like very close to therapy and so he
i've been working with him for years and
and uh you know really he definitely
helped me attune
to a the fact that there was
notwithstanding my
meditation practice quite a bit of anger
and b that beneath that
was a lot of fear since you invoked the
name
of the coach with the spider tattoo i'm
going to use that
and ask you a question that uh i'll
paraphrase i'm sure i'm not getting it
entirely right but
the question that jury often asks is how
are you well he encourages you to phrase
it in the first person so how am i
complicit
in creating the conditions i say i don't
want yes
that is that is a colonia-ism
how would you answer that or actually
how would you have answered that in
say the pre-2010 and has the answer
changed
i suspect it's funny that's not a
question i mean i've heard him ask that
question but it's not one we've worked
on a lot so i don't have a ready answer
because i'm going to have to process it
a lot
you know in real time i suspect it all
comes back to the fear and anxiety too
that in particular pre-2010 or whatever
before i started getting really serious
about meditation
but even after two because it didn't it
doesn't solve all of your problems
hence the whole 10 percent stick the
the i would say that the anger that
flows out of the fear
was creating a lack of collegiality for
me and my work
relationships and could sometimes be a
really
tough thing for my wife to deal with as
well and i want to be clear it's not
like i was a rage-a-holic or anything
like that it's more just like um
i could go inward i could withdraw and
that was hard for people to
that is hard for people to read but and
nonetheless i could also lose my temper
and that would be
scary or annoying for people and i think
now so back then it would say
if i felt like i had too much stress in
my life too much conflict in my life
i think i was complicit because i hadn't
taken a look at
the sources of my own fear and anger and
i would say
now the answer would change to be more
around
the anxiety which i worry one of the
things i really
learned from jerry and why jerry focuses
on the leadership in organizations is
that
a primary thesis of his is that when you
have unexamined baggage
as a leader in an organization you
pass your pathology along willy-nilly
throughout the rest of the organization
it just starts to mirror your
idiosyncrasies
and now that i'm you know helping to run
an organization i mean i mean i guess i
have a kind of a leadership role at abc
news but
within the 10 happier company you know i
worry about
and jerry and i have talked a lot about
my anxiety
leading you know bleeding out into the
rest of the organization and i really
have to watch that
you mentioned long ago in this
conversation
actually let's not go long ago there is
there's something that i bookmarked
for later discussion but the withdrawal
the uh not in the drug sense but the
emotional withdrawing uh is something
i'd like to dig into a little bit
so i'm looking at some of my notes and
one says
that you've had the experience or the
habit of tending to avoid social
engagements
is that related to the withdrawing are
you more of
would you consider yourself an introvert
i ask in part because
i generally
withdraw from social engagements i find
them more depleting than re-energizing
generally speaking particularly if it's
a larger group particularly if it's
people i don't know
very well from the outset could you
speak to
any aspect of that non-question that i
just threw at you
it's it's not a non-question that was
super redundant what i just said not
annoying question but it's a it's a real
question
and i i think actually the reason why i
i've had a big shift on this
i was not very good at
keeping up with my friends and
prioritizing social engagement
for a long time largely
well it started a little bit when i
stopped doing drugs and that
had a could have a negative relation you
know relationship on
your friendships with it can have a
negative impact on your friendships with
people who are still partying
so there was that and then i as i
started to write 10 happier and then
all of the stuff that happened after 10
happier like launching a podcast and a
company all that stuff i was just
i told myself i was too busy and so i
was really
like letting my friendship starve
i am not an introvert though i actually
get an
enormous amount of energy i think i have
some introverted tendencies annika
and i started annika harris and i
started talking recently about this and
we never finished the conversation chad
i think she might have a good diagnosis
for me but
i have some introversion in me but
generally speaking i really
love seeing my friends and there was an
episode a couple of years ago where my
wife and my son and i
went to a rooftop party it was a goodbye
party for two of my colleagues at abc
news
and it was just a small group of my abc
news colleagues
and it was so much fun and i got in the
car afterwards
and i was like why am i in such a good
mood and
i realized it's because i don't do this
anymore i i'm not
making this a priority and so over the
last couple of years i've
completely switched that and which is
hard during covid
but you know we we moved out of the city
we had the incredible
good luck to be able to our lease was
ending in the city so we were able to
get out of our apartment in the city
and rent a house up in the suburbs and
it has a pool and so
over the summer we're able to like bring
our friends over
all the time and my happiness level went
through the roof
from regular social engagement and this
actually speaks to
a huge issue in our culture which is the
lack of prioritization
of social connection which has led to a
pandemic
that predated the current pandemic which
was the pandemic of loneliness
which is a major contributing factor
from the evidence i've seen
to depression anxiety drug abuse
suicide um i you know there are many
contributing factors here
from the way we live you know the way
our societies are structured
um the the myth of individualism where
we think we can do everything alone
social media which is further sort of
uh taking us out of you know seeing each
other in person
and i think this is a gigantic
social issue and on an individual level
to be practical about it for your
listeners
i think being deliberate about
cultivating
interpersonal relationships will pay
unbelievable dividends you know we've
talked a lot about meditation but
i'm not a meditation fundamentalist i i
think there are many
many many levers to pull here and
there's that
one incredibly powerful one is just
having good relationships
it's just right there in our evolution
you know we evolved
to be social creatures this is how we
survived we killed the mastodon as a
group
and yet we have as the great writer
johann
hari has written we're the first
generation to voluntarily
dissolve the tribe but we need the tribe
and so making your own tribe and if
you're introverted
you know for you tim it might be about
like smaller close-knit
group of really really powerful intimate
relationships but we need those
relationships and
i would recommend to people like being
super deliberate about keeping those up
even in a pandemic maybe especially in a
pandemic
yes so the 10 happier shtick
your words not mine you use those
earlier i want
i have a comment and then a whole slew
of questions
so the the comment is i think you called
it the 10 happier shtick
because you were alluding to the fact
that
many of the emotional experiences that
you had before meditation you still have
post meditation and it made me think
of i'm going to paraphrase here but a
parable
in a book called awareness by anthony
demello who is a jesuit priest
and i suppose you call him a
psychotherapist or therapist but
tells this parable of this enlightened
master who says
before enlightenment i was depressed
after enlightenment
i was still depressed but it goes on
to say that the relationship to the
depression
changed and i'm gonna take some creative
liberties here but in
in brief effectively says you know
before
enlightenment i was depressed and then
after enlightenment i continued to
experience what we would call depression
but it was more of a
there is depression or i am making
myself
depressed and it was that level of
observer status that
allows you to or certainly
facilitates decreasing the half-life of
depression right sam
harris has talked about the half-life of
anger and if you can reduce that from
like two hours to two minutes or five
hours to one hour
the benefits are huge even if the
subjective experience at times can still
feel the same
kind of pre and post so i just i thought
that was
something very important that you
alluded to
when you were calling it the 10 happier
shtick so let's talk about that
you publish 10 happier excellent title
by the way
thank you and it does very well it
spawns
all of these various businesses
apps and so on that both contribute
i think incredible tools to those who
are open to them and has also made you
into
i'm going to use a little bit of
hyperbole here but
a very unlikely self-help guru
right so
you have spent a lot of time as and and
probably still do as the the skeptic the
debunker
of self-help pundits in in a sense
when you were writing or dis or
contemplating writing
what became 10 happier how did you
approach it
and i think there are probably quite a
few things that i'm
digging for here and one is how did you
create
a book that or think about creating it
that ended up being very successful in a
hugely crowded category
right because i would imagine at the
time if you had said to some of your
friends like hey i'm thinking about
writing a book on meditation they were
like
well yeah if you want to be number you
know 5 million
676 000 on the list of meditation books
knock yourself out nonetheless it cut
through the clutter so
how did you think about writing this
book i mean you mentioned a little bit
in brief earlier but
it really cut through and stood out so
effectively in a crowded category i
would just love to hear
anything that you would have to say
about that what i mentioned to barbara
walters one time that i was working on
this book
she turned to me and literally said
don't quit your day job
so
[Laughter]
i had no re this was an uh complete i
say this as somebody who's already outed
himself as
an atheist or an agnostic or whatever
but like i this was a
complete leap of faith i i had no reason
to believe
this was going to be a success i did not
think it was going to be a success
i thought it was going to be mildly
embarrassing and then go away
my let me push back just for a second
though a book is a hell of a heavy lift
like that is not an easy thing to do
so what what were you hoping this book
would do because as we both know
book economics if you are a huge
outlier can produce some income but
they're not the best it's like relying
on music royalties or something like
that
why do it you you might not have had
high expectations but maybe you had some
hopes related to it
so the right amount of work there was
the fantasy
which i really was aware that was was a
fantasy
and then there was the thing that kept
me going day to day
so the fantasy yes was that i
was kind of like a man still i am like a
b
or c level network news person who
you know i i worried about ever like
really cutting through in that industry
and you know also could see quite
clearly that
it's not an industry that's kind to its
senior statesman so
you know what was my future here and so
like my fantasy was that i would create
a whole new
brand for myself in some ways and that
it would really help a lot of people
who would reflexively reject meditation
in the ordinary course of events but if
talked about in the right way
would really embrace it and so that was
my
fantasy but i didn't allow myself to
indulge in that that much because
all the messages i was getting including
from my own publisher
were that this was not going first of
all i couldn't sell the book
i had a fancy book agent and he couldn't
even he got me
one meeting and i and that one
add yes and that one editor
bought it but for very little money and
was the title ten percent happier well
okay so he said they then tried to
bargain me up to 20 or 30 happier
and i was like you don't get the joke
and they also at one point tried to get
me to change the title to be happy now
uh which i i did have like a real temper
tantrum about that
um and so it was it was not good i mean
the initial print run was 15 000.
i really didn't think it was going i
honestly
didn't think it was going to succeed but
of course i had the fantasies but the
the re the thing that got me going from
day to day
because i remember i had many
conversations with people in my life
including my brother who's
really like my closest advisor and i'm
probably the smartest person i know and
i'm i remember him just kind of
marveling at like dude you are
it took me five years to write that book
and he was just like you are spending so
much time on this thing and you have
no idea you know if it's going to be
published or whether it's going to be a
success
what are you doing this for and i think
it was because i needed to figure this
stuff
out and i know you know this tim because
you've written so many books like
uh there was a great expression i heard
once that you should only write a book
if you have to
and i felt like i had to write this book
because
i was trying to figure out these
incredibly important issues to me around
anxiety and ambition and and this
the voice in the head and and and the
remedies for that
or the ways to work with it i only fully
started to get some level of
understanding
as i was writing and so that's really
what kept me going
five years that's a long time yeah when
did you have
the book i'm writing now is much to the
consternation of the people in my
orbit is going to take me at minimum
four what are you working on right now
can you say or is that undercover i
think it's similar to what you're
working on in some ways is um
because i know you're writing a book
about healing and i would
say i've only recently started using
this formulation of i think it's a book
about love
which is and i i think love has gotten a
really bad
rap because it comes down to us through
hollywood movies and love songs and
all you need is love which i love that
song but like it's definitely not true
like you also
need to brush your teeth and whatever
there are lots of other things you need
and i also think we we don't think about
love in the right way our understanding
is kind of limited to the
romantic or maybe the you know the way
we feel about our kids but
in a lot of buddhist circles that you
can think about love as
kind of anything north of neutrality
just like the human capacity
to care and and you can also think of it
as
omnidirectional which i think is perhaps
the most interesting aspect here which
is and this gets to the hug the dragon
aspect of it it's like
if you can start to love yourself and i
don't mean love yourself like
you're walking around giving yourself
hugs or talking about how great you are
but like
have some warmth towards your own inner
ugliness
or as ram das has said before he passed
he said
it's not about defeating your neuroses
it's about becoming a connoisseur of
them
like if you could think about like
self-love in that way
well that's like the unlock that can
improve your relationships and lead to
a really virtuous cycle of okay so your
inner weather is bombier
then your relationships get better and
as a consequence of your relationships
getting better because
we know that relationships are in many
ways like the apex predator of like
self-care
techniques or self-care like aspects of
self-care
then then your inner weather gets better
and then your relationships get better
and it goes into a virtuous
cycle upward spiral and so for me like
that's what i mean when i'm talking
about
love i wrote a subsequent book to 10
happier called
meditation for fidgety skeptics and i
wrote it really quick and i made
myself and everybody around me miserable
and in the end the book was fine but it
wasn't like
it's not as impactful i don't think has
as 10 happier and so my goal for this
next book and i may fail but i'm willing
to make
the leap of faith and the investment
largely because i'm trying to figure
this [ __ ] out for myself
and so it's just going to take me a long
time books
what a what an everest the books
are and i'm on the fence you know i have
i will be honest i have
god knows how many words i mean fifty
thousand hundred thousand hundred and
fifty thousand words
gathered largely in the form of notes
and rough drafts and so on for this
healing
this book about i should i should
personalize it because i don't think
it's
one size fits all but my own healing
journey
and i'm not gonna lie that i have
become largely demotivated
which is not necessarily a bad thing
after releasing this podcast about the
childhood abuse because that was the big
reveal that was
going to be in a sense the nucleus
of this book and i feel like the
live dialogue with
my friend debbie millman was a a more
suitable format
in a way it was a more emotionally
charged
appropriate format for that reveal
than text i'm not saying that's true for
all things i think that
many many things are better explored in
the printed word
but since releasing that into the wild
i have all of these notes and i'm i'm
not
i've lost a bit of the
the internal pressure and the uh it's
going to be really dramatic but sort of
the
like the devil whipping me at my back to
get that out into the world
if that makes any sense which i think is
is a good thing in a sense
because i'm
having i'm not having to but i'm
choosing to
leave more slack in the system which i
have done for the last
month or two and it's deeply
uncomfortable
deeply deeply deeply uncomfortable it's
like
you know if you're thrashing around in
the kiddie pool it's like yeah you don't
have to look at the stuff that's at the
bottom of the pool
but you're just creating so much surface
froth with
like frenetic activity and lots and lots
of
projects and so on which i've always not
just done i would say
to cover things but because i enjoy that
it's like the uh
kind of parker sixth gear to borrow from
your
from your friends uh two gear two-year
analogy
when do you feel most
at ease and expansive or
when do you feel the greatest sense of
spaciousness
i'm going to answer that but can i just
go back to your book for a second
and i and i don't say this to be a devil
whipping you and i think it's totally
fine
if you never write the book and because
the service you provided
by releasing that podcast is already
immense
so i say this very gingerly because i
again it's not to apply pressure but
it's maybe too
it's a perhaps weak attempt at
re-motivation if that's even appropriate
because i think there's a difference i
mean because that the podcast was
stupendous
in in many ways because you know i uh of
course for people who
suffered trauma and as you guys exposed
on there
you know it's or or described on there
it may be as high as one
of every three women and one in every
six men and perhaps even higher given
the shame around
reporting it among men so that that's a
huge population but
beyond that there were the themes that
you described that really resonated with
me who
who luckily didn't suffer any childhood
abuse there are the themes you described
in there that are very similar to the
themes that i'm describing which is
you know viewing these adaptive
patterns behavioral patterns and
storylines that we
adopt in childhood you know you talked
about sort of a dissociation which
made a lot of sense was it was brilliant
as a kid but not so useful as you got
older
that the universality i think of
bringing some warmth
exploring through various modalities
you've described
therapy cbt in particular but also
psychotropic drugs and meditation
hearing you walk through that narrative
in a much more granular way and
letting us watch your process
i think there there's an enormous amount
of value you could provide there i
again i'm not saying you're [ __ ] up
if you don't do it
but i could see how it would serve a lot
of people if you did do it
i appreciate the pep talk dan i it's not
it's not absolutely off the table it's
not absolutely off the table i
have a f a uh you know seth gooden would
sort of give me a stiff drink and give
me another talking to if you heard me
saying this but i have this
i think developed a certain apprehension
around writing because i really haven't
written a monster book not that this
would need to be a monster book but it
probably would knowing me and my
my tendency to write phone books was
2011
so it's been a long time i mean you have
tools of titans which did have
quite a bit of original writing i mean
probably 150
150 pages original writing and but it
was connective tissue for the rest
of the book tribe of mentors which was
like one of the
sort of incredible demonstration of
efficiency and having other people write
a book for you
which i can't recommend highly enough so
there's
some apprehension around it but i'll be
getting back into the writing game and i
think i need to sort of sharpen up my
ice skates and take
a bunch of shots on goal that are in a
practice setting before i get back to
real live gameplay but i suspect i'll
get there
very early on in this conversation you
mentioned i don't want to say reverence
that's too strong but an appreciation
for
how adherence to these various religions
you were exposed to
through your assignments had
regular regular cadence of contemplating
their place in the cosmos
contemplating the universe in whatever
capacity
have you found an opportunity or vehicle
for doing that yourself or is that still
a
non-essential or non-present at least
element in the puzzle that is dan harris
no it's totally essential and it really
comes in the form of buddhism
and it's not just buddhism i don't want
to be
too sectarian about this it's just
living an exam and examined life
generally
and so for me that can happen in the
form of my meditation practice and going
on meditation retreats
but it's also you know hosting a podcast
where i get to interview
all of being peop all sorts of people
including you
it's listening to other people's
podcasts yours
sam's our mutual friend uh peter atiyah
it's reading books so
it's walking in nature it's it's
anything that
can jar you out of the constricted sense
of being
an ego being a small self peering
fretfully
out at the world through your eye holes
and
more into
god this this is where you get into this
sort of cliched stuff but
like uh feeling connected
um the
and so i haven't toured much with
uh psychedelics although i'm very
interested in it
but you know you can get that in
psychedelics i can get it pretty easily
in meditation
i can get it in socializing with my
friends
i get it with i have a five-year-old and
a son and he is just like
just a constant source of this and also
like
worry and frustration too in engaging in
the lifelong exercise and project of
being in a marriage
so there's so many for me that seems
like such a target-rich environment for
contemplating externally and
internally i mean that has been just
such an incredible
shift in my life since
those days when i was reluctantly
exposed to
you know the faithful and had that
encoded sense of maybe there was
something i was missing but i didn't
want
exactly what these guys were doing i
feel like i figured that out
i mean i've figured out much but i
figured out the various
access points for me to start this this
investigation
just a quick side note on psychedelics
for people who may not
have any exposure to other conversations
about them
this may seem odd but i just pulled it
up because i thought it might be
fun and instructor for folks there's a
book called the island written by aldous
huxley oh yeah i've read it and
okay so aldous huxley also a doors of
perception
considered the island his most important
work it was a novel
about paula this utopian island
and there's this psychedelic
brew you know psychedelic medicine
called moksha
moksha and there's a there's a portion
if you don't mind me sort of indulging
myself
on this podcast i'll just read this real
briefly so here we go this is a dialogue
between two characters in the novel the
moksha medicine takes you to the same
place you get to in meditation
so why bother to meditate you might as
well ask why bother to eat dinner
but according to you the moksha medicine
is dinner it's a banquet
she said emphatically and that's
precisely why there has to be meditation
you can't have banquets every day
they're too rich and last too long
besides banquets are provided by a
caterer
you don't have any part in the
preparation of them for your everyday
diet you have to do your own cooking the
moksha medicine comes
as an occasional treat in theological
terms the moksha medicine prepares one
for the reception of gratuitous graces
pre-mystical visions or the full-blown
mystical experience
meditation is one of the ways in which
one cooperates with those gratuitous
graces
how by cultivating the state of mind
that makes it possible for the dazzling
ecstatic insights to become permanent
and habitual illuminations by getting to
know oneself to the point where one
won't be compelled by one's unconscious
to do all the ugly
absurd self-stultifying things that one
so often finds oneself doing
and i think that's a great i suppose
description
narrative painting of a scene to
compare or put side by side psychedelic
compounds and experiences with
meditation because i think
the tendency among also
many type a driven personalities
when they hear the description of say a
very strong psilocybin experience or
ayahuasca experience as 15 years of
therapy in
two nights they're like great i've been
looking for the shortcut
let me go do this and get on the front
lines and take
a thousand bullets to the face in a
short period of time to get this
over with so i can move into my more
enlightened phase
and that's a very problematic approach
and
can backfire can destabilize can really
untether people also
i use the expression ontological hives
earlier in the conversation which
i don't know i'm not sure where that
came from but there is a term that
i don't know if this scientist would be
comfortable with me using his name but
very well-known scientist
would call ontological shock where
people come out of these experiences
so i'll just use this the same word
destabilized because of the richness
vividness comprehensiveness of
their experience under psychedelics that
they
lose their faith in the fidelity and the
realness
of this let's call it ordinary reality
and that may sound like word salad to
some
but it is it can be a not just
terrifying
but persistent issue for some folks
and you know there is a reason that
psychedelics
prior to that becoming the default term
were called psychomemetics right they
were
used to instigate what clinicians at the
time
assumed to be psychotic episodes even
though
neurobiologically they're actually quite
different if you were to look at say
functional mri or the activity they're
quite different but subjectively
they can seem quite similar so that is
that is not something you want to do on
a daily basis it may be something you
never want to do
but meditation allows you to sort of
access
many of the same channels without having
it at spinal tap
11 of volume so that's soliloquy
complete
but if we flash forward say
three years i like three years for these
kind of thought exercises
for you to be in retrospect looking back
at the past three years this is three
years from now
what would you like to see in your own
life
that's deliberately very broad but if we
were to
flash forward to dan harris three years
from today
and sort of ask are you happy with the
last three years are you satisfied are
you content
pleased choose your adjective what
assessment would you would you run what
are the things you would look for
anything in particular well look there's
a superficial level that's not
unimportant but the superficial level of
you know i'm really focused on
professionally on building a brand
and a company that is
going to help a lot of people and grow
and be good for our employees
and you know writing the book is part is
you know sort of related to that
and so all that stuff which i would put
on the more superficial end of the
spectrum
well again not being unimportant that's
there i'd say
deeper is is this stuff again just to
invoke this cheesy little
hug the dragon phrase you know like that
seems to me like to be incredibly
onward leading and to have
profound ripple effects for like every
aspect of my existence
the more i can switch my response
to my own to use this phrase again sort
of inner ugliness
from anger or just sort of blind
obedience
to a sort of slightly amused
warmth that just strikes me as like
really consequential in terms of how i'm
treating myself and then how i'm
treating other people
and then all of the ramifications of
that dynamic
and so it will show up in lots of ways
like how am i
about you know my own feelings about
like my own body
or toward food or toward productivity
or how am i in my marriage how is all of
that
modeling which of course your kids going
to see
how is that all impacting him and what
kind of human he's going to become
and all the ripple effects of his
actions in the world
so yeah that seems like the project to
me and it's not just
as simple as you know you talked before
about like kind of
and i didn't respond to it because we
moved on but there was you were talking
before about
like selflessness or not self the
the uh the idea in buddhism that there
is no solid self here so instead of
saying i'm angry you can just say there
is anger
and i see that as related to the it's
not just that you have a warm
relationship to your anger
you see that there the anger isn't as
solid like
identifying with it as my anger
instead of seeing it and this is kind of
radical as
nature we again think of ourselves
as atomized individual egos
right just nature is outside of us we're
looking at it through
this lens of me but absolutely it
can't be true to go to the cliche about
like
you're the the atoms that make up your
body are from the first exploded stars
you are part of nature and so therefore
all of the horrible little
things that you're thinking all of these
things that you that feel
so much like you that's nature too
and and that helps you not identify with
it not
it doesn't have to be your anger anymore
it can just be
anger and so the combination of
viewing it with some warmth and then
viewing it as just nature as a selfless
phenomenon that you don't have to
claim that project
seems like a i would love to be
further and further along in the
development of those twin
mutually reinforcing capacities over the
next three years
yeah me too you mentioned the weather
patterns
earlier in the conversation right i mean
getting i very uh rarely i would say
never
get angry at the day for being overcast
or
raining or fill the blank right so
getting closer to that level of
equanimity
uh detachment slash connection
with the occurrences of emotions and
viewing them similarly that's something
to aspire to
you can view your emotion as a weather
pattern this is not my analogy exactly
you can view the what is a hurricane or
any storm it's a confluence of
meteorological atmospheric events that
come together to create a storm but this
you can't find any
core to the storm there is no essential
nugget of storm it's a coming together
of a variety of
phenomena and the same is true for your
anchor but we just don't see it that way
and so
starting to just play with the idea of
like
this anger may just be a naturally
occurring phenomenon just like a storm
as joseph goldstein often says takes the
nutriment
of i out of it um and makes it
so much less loaded there's a question
that keeps popping to mind for me i
don't know why i want to ask but i'm
going to ask
if i were to ask dr bianca
your partner in crime partner in life
or not i if i were to rather put her in
a situation with you where she is saying
to you
dan i am so proud of you for dot dot dot
just looking back over the last could be
last few years could be last week it
could be anything but
what might she say to you i don't have
to guess actually because
jerry colona not that long ago he and i
were having a skype session
and he asked me something the effect of
like what would be a similar question to
what you
just asked like what would bianca say
and i said well we don't have to guess
let's bring her in and
she she's pretty shy so she was mad at
me for doing this but i
pulled her over in front of the camera
and he asked her but she loves him so
she was happy to see him so she
asked him a bunch of questions he asked
her a bunch of questions and
and she said the following which was
so just by way of background i got
involved with jerry because i had a 360
review
this was two and a half years ago for
those of you
yeah okay so have you ever had one i
have okay it took me a while to recover
to recover from it okay so i'm still
recovering this was like two and a half
years ago
um and i had a 360 review i did it as
like a cute little thing that i thought
might be like a good element for
a book that i was writing now let's do
you want to just for people who don't
know what it is describe what this is
yes i will uh so a 360 review
is a corporate thing mostly where you
uh where you hire a a company an
executive will hire a company or the
executive's boss will hire a company
that comes in and interviews
said executives superiors peers and
subordinates
so you get a 360 view of how they're
performing in the company
i with jerry did the colonoscopy version
of this
where we interviewed 16 people both from
my professional life and my personal
life so like
my wife my brother there be dragons
okay exactly there be dragons which by
the way
i've learned how to hug but i didn't i
didn't know this
i didn't have a lot of sort of warmth
toward my inner
dragons in the when we did this two and
a half years ago
and the results were devastating
devastating i mean i was because
everybody
the feedback is reported anonymously yes
yes
right that's a key point it's it's like
basically i
got to eavesdrop on a conversation that
16 of my closest
colleagues and friends and family
members had behind my back
and and all the feedback was anonymized
and it was i was sick for days
and that's the book i'm writing now is
that's that's the panic attack of the
book i'm writing now so the first book
began with a panic attack this book
begins with the 360. and
um so i thought it was going to be like
a cute little device i would use for a
book it turned out to be so devastating
that it became
the whole book my sort of dealing with
what i learned in this 360 and
it's the best thing that ever happened
to me as horrifying one of the best
things that ever happened to me as
horrifying as it was
and so anyway jerry called bianca over
and she
said that she was incredibly proud of me
for dealing with
all of the contents of the 360 which she
has read
first time she read it she cried
she said she was very proud of my
dealing with it forthrightly and
really digging in and i said at the
moment well
bianca you know like i'm writing a book
about this so i'm essentially getting
paid to do this work
and i don't know like i have trouble
giving myself too much credit and she
had she's had to say this to me time and
time again and
it's really a relief she's like i don't
care why you're doing it
you're doing it and you can't fake the
doing of it
whatever your motivations are like if
you're really doing it you're really
doing it
and the benefits for her for my son
potentially if i do my job correctly and
write the book well the benefits for
other people
should be real so that was re i was just
i
audio record all of my conversations
with jerry because i often write about
them and
i was just re-listening to that the
other day
so your question is serendipitous
because i haven't happen to have her
words fresh
fresh in my mind and yeah it's very
moving for me to hear
wow i don't care why you're doing it
that's a good partner right there
that's a good intervention just a few
more questions
we'll do we'll do a couple of we'll end
on some some candy
some shorter questions although the
answers don't have to be
short books you've gifted the most to
other people
outside of of your own what books have
you gifted the most
to other people anything that comes to
mind and why yeah so the books that i
most recommend are won't surprise you
all going to be um with one exception
they're all going to be sort of
meditation books although the one
exception
has some pretty strong ties to it too
for people are interested in learning
more about this i recommend
why buddhism is true by robert wright
waking up by sam harris
buddhism without beliefs by stephen
batchelor real happiness
by sharon salzberg and now there's a new
entrant which would be
you belong by 7a selassie the
the non-meditative book i would
recommend but it actually has some
pretty strong dharma overtones
is perhaps the best novel i have ever
read and it was sent to me by seveneyes
alaska i just referenced who wrote that
book you belong she's a meditation
teacher and
she her love language is to send people
books and so she sent me a book recently
and it was called
the overstory did you read it
this is where i'm gonna i'm like gonna
drown in my own
productivity shame because this book has
been recommended to me
so many times it's on my kindle
and i haven't yet gotten past page one
so i i need to read it but please
describe it for people well page one is
tough actually
um i can see why you wouldn't get past
page one because he um
it's a barn burner of a story and so in
fact you should you don't need to look
at this
as homework uh because it's it's in a
massively pleasurable read
the only warning i would give you is
that as
a fellow writer i found the book to be
utterly
humiliating because i realized that he
has
more skill in a single paragraph than i
will ever muster
in my entire writing career this guy is
a force of nature
and the book is about nature the book is
is ostensibly about trees
but it's really about humans and their
relationship to trees and
he is able to render these incredible
characters and
create this really page-turner of a book
that is again sort of ostensibly about
trees which makes it sound very boring
but now i'm fascinated by trees and i
loved the book and i
i just couldn't believe i still can't
believe
how much how talented a writer he is
it's just
it's not fair um
i will just say i will just finally say
that one of the great joys of my life
recently has
you know has been having a son and uh or
a child but he happens to be a boy and
and uh
we move to the suburbs and we're doing
the most
cheesy suburb thing which is he's a cub
scout now and
um he loves nature so we will like we
have these like cub scout pamphlets and
we'll walk around the yard trying to
identify trees and
that has in part been fueled by the
reading of the overstory
do you have any favorite documentaries
or documentaries you most
recommend or tend to recommend a lot and
i i also have question about
well very personal i suppose approach to
documentaries but how would you answer
that
i love i'm a sucker for a rock duck
so i will watch pretty much any
rockumentary
that comes out so i'm obviously the king
of
of them is the the last waltz which is a
martin scorsese movie about the final
concert
put on by the band there actually is a
new documentary called once we were
brothers i believe and it's also about
the band robbie robertson
it's on hulu right now and i loved that
but i will watch like my wife and i just
watched a showtime documentary about the
go-go's and it was
amazing i watched a decidedly mediocre
netflix documentary about the k-pop band
black pink
but i loved it anyway even though it
wasn't really that good
no direction home about bob dylan uh
song exploder which is uh the new
netflix show
where they they do a half hour on like a
song i watched one last night
just last night about losing my religion
by rem
and it's basically a doc a little mini
documentary about
how they made the song and ended up
telling the story of the band as part of
that and so
yeah that's what i find myself watching
when i'm looking to relax
so perhaps people are not looking to
relax necessarily but
could you please describe guardians of
the amazon
i feel i would be remiss not to bring
that up i did a documentary like an
hour-long documentary
about this amazonian indigenous tribe
we finished it and posted it in february
it's on
youtube you can watch it there it's also
on hulu and i went and followed this
indigenous tribe they started their own
paramilitary organization to go out and
do this incredibly dangerous thing of
arresting
illegal loggers illegal loggers are
basically the tip of the spear when it
comes to deforestation the way it works
is
the loggers come in they take all the
valuable trees and then
then people come in and flatten the
whole part of the forest and turn it
into grazing land for cattle
if you want to know why we have so much
deforestation you can largely blame your
cheeseburger
this tribe though is incredible and we
embedded with them on a mission and they
uh we were right it does like so much
action unfolded in front of our lenses
as they
went out and found these loggers and
they're armed with bows and arrows
machetes
muskets rifles pistols is extraordinary
it is visually and emotionally arresting
if people just watch
the uh trailer for guardians of the
amazon
my reasons for saying that will be
extremely extremely clear
you've given a few mottos a few mantras
if you had a billboard metaphorically
speaking to reach billions of people
message to put up could be a quote could
be a word could be
an image could be anything at all what
might you put up on that billboard
i don't know if this is if this would
work on a billboard
but the most exciting idea i've ever
encountered
and i think it's now my job on the
planet to
spread the word about this which is in
part why i was
badgering you about writing your book
because i think your book
makes this point will make this point in
a beautiful way
the most exciting idea is that the mind
is trainable
that we are not stuck with
all the things we don't like about
ourselves that you
can through various modalities including
meditation therapy
psychedelics walks in nature
working on your relationships there's so
many ways that you can
train your mind i'm obsessed with music
as
and i used to back when record stores
were a thing i would i would always go
to newbury comics in boston and spent an
hour or so flipping through the
new records and they would had this like
white board that listed
all of the um upcoming releases but i
was so
interested to see like what new records
were going to come out and
and there was an expression above the
list and it said
all dates can change so can you
that is the truth dude like you can
change and like you you've demonstrated
this is why i was so sort of galvanized
by
listening to your podcast and i knew
some of it because you when you came in
to do my podcast a
while ago you actually i think we had
stopped rolling but you had told me some
of the story and so i was aware of
some of what i was going to hear on the
podcast but just hearing more about the
work you've done to recover from this
grievous injury makes that point
that we can change it's not i'm not
saying it's gonna be easy
but it is doable and what are the
options
yeah all dates can change and so can you
i like it and that stuck clearly i mean
that
that that i guess what was it sign
poster board the letters that fit into
those grooves i'm just imagining one of
those
announcement boards in high school all
dates can change and so can you
i think that's a good place to start to
wrap up dan is there anything else you
would like to
say request complaints
comments anything you would like to
posit or request of my audience
listening
no i'm very grateful to you for having
me on thank you and it was actually
it was really fun so that's all i have
to say
this has been a whole hell of a lot of
fun dan i always enjoy
our conversations and can't wait
to see the new book when that is done
and the people can find you online quite
easily they can find the book 10 happier
also the follow-up meditation fidgety
skeptics a 10 happier how-to book
you have the ten percent happier company
with the app and so on
twitter at dan b harris one s instagram
dan harris facebook at dan harris abc
is there anywhere else any other urls or
anything that
that might be helpful to mention for
people who want to see and learn more
about what you're up to
i mean you can check out the podcast
we've had illustrious guests such as tim
ferriss
and many of the all of the meditation
teachers who've been referenced in the
course of this show our regulars on the
show on the show we where
we post episodes twice a week so um
basically it's a fiesta of the if you
enjoy if you like thinking about
human flourishing that's that's all we
talk about and just like tim
and sam and others do as well so that's
the you can check that out what is the
name of your podcast also called 10
happier
easy to remember brand continuity you
know you i know you're a big investor in
in in companies and so brand continuity
is reasonably important
[Laughter]
yes very important dates can change and
so can you
but your brand shouldn't change every
tuesday that is something that you
probably want to keep more constant
uh dan once again thank you so much for
taking the time this was
just a great way to wrap up
this week we're recording on a friday
and uh really appreciate also what
you're doing in the world
and what you're sharing i think it's
incredibly valuable
and incredibly practical also coming at
it from
the perspective of a skeptical
investigative
wartime journalist
who is loathe to believe in any
mythologies or fairy tales i think that
appeals to an entire large segment of
the population
who would otherwise not be open to even
test driving any
of these these tools that can so
demonstrably help
so it's it's a it's quite a service that
you put into the world so i want to
thank you for that
and to everybody listening
everything we've talked about will be
linked to in the show notes so you can
find all of that at tim.log
forward slash podcast until next time
thank you for tuning in hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the the world of the esoteric
as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to
4hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
theragun i have two theraguns
and they're worth their weight in gold
i've been using them every single day
whether you're an elite athlete or just
a regular person trying to get through
your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things
that's why i use the theragun i use it
at night i use it after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom
of my feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this stuff and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
and you really have to feel the
theragun's signature power amplitude and
effectiveness
to believe it it's one of my favorite
gadgets in my house at this point
so i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's
thera t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n try theragon
risk-free for
30 days there's no substitute for the
gen 4 theragon with an oled screen
that's oled
for those wondering that's organic light
emitting diode screen
personalized theragun app an incredible
combination of quiet and power
so go to theragun.com tim right now and
get your gen 4th era gun
today or you can watch the videos on the
site we show you all sorts of different
ways to use it
a lot of runner friends of mine use them
on their it bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start at
just 199 i said i have two i have the
prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep
my god am i in love with eight sleep
good sleep is the ultimate
game changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes
of poor sleep and heat has always been
my nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating advancing but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight
sleeping it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about
the best tools for sleep enhancing sleep
and ate sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat then we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250
off of the pod pro cover that's a lot
simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m eight
eightsleep.com
tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
you